ah I'm like Mario
oh look at me oh look at me okay so I
know what I gotta do a little bit hello
hoody what you hooting about over there
where are you going wait come back wait
no hang on I need I think I need you I
think ah jiminy Christmas
where'd you go oh god no uncomfortable
for that to be stuck permanently
underground like that okay anyway what
am I doing here
[Music]
[Laughter]
so whoa what is hell is that
[Music]
music stopped
mister orchestra man you could kick it
up any time now it's a little weird
being alone in this little plant I don't
want to play it I do not want to play
Hey wow you are pretty you seem to be
ball Besant oh all this I'm just gonna
like caress your sweet luscious oh wow
wow wow yeah see how you missed me and I
don't miss me because I'm not bad my
life where to go
you